ET has learned that those reports that
Fox News hosts Sean Hannity and Ainsley
Earhart are dating are true we did have
the idea to come to your house with a
marching band this morning and surprise
you the long-running romance was first
confirmed by The Daily Mail when they
obtained photos of the pair on Tuesday
showing the TV personalities cozied up
at a restaurant and traveling together
with Ainsley's seven-year-old daughter
in Palm Beach Florida Fox News is not
commenting on the reports of their
relationship Sean if you all knew what
we know about him he's the most generous
person he pays for lunch and dinners for
his entire staff on radio and TV every
single day he doesn't care what they
order he has given so many wonderful
generous gifts to people that have
needed things to pay for funerals and to
put kids through college here at the
network people that have been a part of
his life people who don't make as much
money so you're just a really good
person Sean and you've helped all of our
careers
one word kindness you know what you just
Sean and Ainsley first sparked romance
rumors three years ago but have remained
tight-lipped about their love I want to
put you on the spot out of the three of
us do you have a favorite anchor yes he
does yeah definitely it's just between
Steve and Ainsley for sure
her daughter Hayden with her ex-husband
former Clemson Tigers quarterback Will
Proctor the two married in 2012 and the
journalist filed for divorce in 2018.
Sean was previously married to Jill
Rhodes for over two decades in 2020 they
announced their divorce several years
after quietly separating they share two
children a 24 year old son Sean and 22
year old daughter Mary as for Sean and
Ainsley they were first romantically
linked in 2019. news of their
relationship broke on Tuesday but on TV
it was business as usual on Sean's show
Hannity welcome to Hannity tonight did
Merrick Garland your attorney general
did he lie unto oath about the FBI
sending undercover agents into Catholic
churches and other denominations well
Senator Josh Hawley thinks that he did
lie he will join us in a few minutes
also there was a major intelligence leak
at the Pentagon so is the by
Administration now and capable of
guarding our most sensitive Secrets as
for Ainsley she made no mention of the
reports on Wednesday's fox and friends
thank you so much Peter people are
criticizing him for being there for
going to find out about his lineage uh
couldn't he have done this after he was
allowed you know after he finishes his
presidency Azores tells the Daily Mail
the two are extremely happy together and
have been for a while it's not a
surprise to anyone who knows them but
they're very private people and prefer
to keep their personal life private and
low-key
[Music]